- There's like those
people that you're like,
"Oh, they have an amazing Instagram"
because it's just like a
lot of peoples' dream lives.
- Gigi, gorgeous.
- The Kardashians.
- Kylie Jenner.
- I love Kylie.
- When the Kardashians post a
photo on their private jets,
I feel like I should be on there.
- I mean, what isn't
inspirational about a private jet?
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- The whole lifestyle
associated with private jets
is very exclusive and unattainable,
so BuzzFeed reached out to JetSuite
and we coordinated this whole shoot today.
- I really like the idea
of tricking my friends.
- Oh, I'm definitely going to be
pretending like this is regular.
- I went shopping this morning, so...
I bought the jacket and I
bought the dress this morning.
I really wanted to kind of embody
what I thought a jetsetter would look like
and I feel like I did that.
- Oh my gosh!
- I'm obsessed.
- It's more than just
like "This picture's cute.
We should post it."
There's a science.
- Of course, we had to bring
our Snapchat spectacles.
Enjoying the private jet life.
Ready?
- Wee!
- I love champagne.
- Dude, I'm snapping everything.
I Snapchat every second
of my f*cking life.
- Good stuff!
- I brought a lot of stuff.
I didn't know what to bring so I
just brought a little bit of everything.
A raccoon, a horse, this
is like a Viking horn.
(laughing)
- This is Cid.
Cid has an Instagram account.
I am a middle school science teacher
and I started an Instagram account
primarily so my students
know that I am "with it".
- [Off camera] Oh, that
is a dangerous choice.
That was cool, though!
- Oh my God, it looks so good.
- You look so, like, expensive.
- Oh thanks!
- I look like I'm either with you
because I want your
money or I owe you money.
- Perception is reality.
- On Instagram, you want
to stay true to yourself
but you also wanna look super dope.
- I'm not gonna post my
cousins' weddings on Instagram.
Something like this, where I'm taking
photos on a private jet, absolutely.
- We're Instagram famous now.
- I was low-key channeling
my inner Kendall.
I can't wait to see the
comments on Instagram.
- Do you really experience something if
it's not on Snapchat
or Instagram nowadays?
- I think Instagram is really important
because people can always
find you no matter what.
- Social media is like
making a paper airplane
out of your resume and
throwing it out the window.
- As a recording artist,
we definitely have to look
like we have more money
than we actually have.
- Kind of a necessary evil, I guess.
- Instagram is only a
highlight reel of your life.
- I feel like people probably
wouldn't be surprised
if you said that you owned this jet.
- I've always kind of been
preparing for this lifestyle,
and it's good to know I was right.
- You do look like Kendall Jenner.
- Thanks. That's sweet.
- Watch out, Kendall Jenner.
She's coming for you.